hi it's it's really good to see you in a
rival
we used yarn to symbolize love and the
bonds between people in our new game we
we tear that bond up right at the start
you lose everything including your spark
but when things are at their darkest you
find hope and you form a new bond and
your spark is rekindled and it leads you
off on an adventure so welcome to
unravel to
it's a game about fresh starts and
second chances these two little souls
who refused to give up and who build
something new and beautiful together and
the whole game is inspired by that
spirit of optimism and togetherness
you see it's all made to be played with
two characters you can play it alone or
you can play it in co-op with a friend
but there's always two characters
they're sharing one yarn and working
together to get through this adventure
this game it's quite different from the
first it's it's both friendlier and more
challenging but above all it's a lot
more playful and we think it's a worthy
successor and I want to show it to you
now so I brought some help so please
welcome Michael to the stage so I
producer out cold wood and we're gonna
try to show you a little bit of what I'm
talking about about how you can play the
game in co-op with yourself essentially
so when you're playing it by yourself
you can essentially pick up the other
character and carry them along through
the more fast-paced segments of the game
and we actually try to include a bit
more of those because we figured that
since it's a co-op game we wanted to
have more like thrill and danger and
kind of wild moments places that were
like fun and exciting
[Music]
and then when you get to the more
hustler area it's like this when you're
problem solving
you can split apart into two and switch
back and forth between the two
characters because that's how we've
essentially designed all the problems
and puzzles of the game that you're
always working together and helping each
other out and utilizing this bond
between you to overcome any obstacle
that you come across
so I guess I'll jump in at this
community so I'm gonna be the red red
one
okay I'll be blue a little celebratory
flip
[Music]
and the bird is back
putting it playing it safe free now I'll
swing
I'll catch you
bat swing up okay you go
[Music]
okay this is the scary part it's African
got it
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I'll go up and distract the grouse
you can I'll sneak up here
[Music]
okay your turn yeah look at me keep it
over to the left now
now we can breathe again finally
[Laughter]
so that's a that's a quick little look
at unravel to
yeah I I really hope you like it and
before I go I just want to send some
some love to the team back home because
working on this game has been and a
completely amazing team effort in so
many levels and everybody has worked so
hard so there's there's a bunch of us
from cold wood here and thank you to
those and thank you to everybody back
home and thank you love you
[Applause]